there's a hidden cause
of arthritis especially if it's in these
knuckles right here the knuckles of the
first digit and the second
on either side
and the knee joint
but this arthritis could be in other
joints as well
and that hidden cause is
iron overload
let me explain
there's a condition called
hemochromatosis okay now that can come
from either a genetic cause
or it could come from your diet or a
medical procedure where you're given a
transfusion or other causes that i'm
going to talk about the point you need
to know is that too much iron in the
body is very very toxic
and our body has no mechanism for
getting rid of too much iron and the
first symptom of iron overload is
arthritis
of the hands and the knees and
specifically like i mentioned the
knuckles now there are a lot of other
symptoms related to iron overload as
well
like fatigue
like abdominal pain or bloating
like liver cirrhosis
insulin resistance
diabetes
erectile dysfunction
hypogonadism
and an overall increase
in infection because
certain pathogens live off of iron so
the more that you feed them the more
that they can grow excessive iron is
especially toxic to the liver as well as
the pancreas and the heart
but this iron can lodge in your liver
and create all sorts of problems so the
more the liver is dysfunctional or
damaged the more problems you're going
to have with iron since the liver is a
really key organ
in hemochromatosis so
if you are on tylenol that destroys the
liver for example or let's say you're on
a high carb diet that leads to a fatty
liver you may have more iron that builds
up in your body now from a dietary
standpoint let's say you do a couple
tablespoons of molasses every day
molasses is loaded with iron and so
that's one source of iron overload but
probably a bigger source would be in the
multivitamin mineral that you're taking
right now so many people are taking the
one a days that are just loaded with
iron and especially the wrong type of
iron
they have what's called elemental iron
which can be absorbed very easily in the
body now the iron you get from
vegetables for example
are not very easily absorbed and so if
you were to have a problem with iron and
only eat red meat for example that could
create a problem but usually the people
that are doing red meat with
sugar or starches like meat and potatoes
or meat and pasta are going to have more
of a problem because of that combination
of protein and sugar creates glycation
which basically is a compound that kind
of clogs everything up and occurs as an
effect from
high blood glucose and then the iron
creates more liver problems which create
more retention of iron so it's a
never-ending cycle so understanding what
to do with your diet is very very
important if you have iron overload but
you need to know if you have this
problem you don't want to start adding
more iron into the diet you don't want
to start taking iron supplements you
don't want to take molasses you don't
want to do anything that weakens or
destroys your liver now
fiber can reduce the iron overload so if
you were to do some red meat with
vegetables for example
that might be a better solution and the
other thing that is in fiber
is called phytic acid and apparently
phytic acid is something that can reduce
your iron so even though i've done
videos on the the negative effects of
phytic acid because it blocks your
absorption of minerals right like zinc
and magnesium but also
iron but if you have an iron overload
situation
taking a supplement with phytic acid
might be beneficial and the form i would
recommend would be something called
inositol hexaphosphate ip6
other things that can reduce iron would
be green tea
cilantro curcetin and even donating
blood can actually be very beneficial so
there are certain minerals in our body
that tend to accumulate and create
destruction especially as we get older
but we have other minerals
that can be easily eliminated from the
body if you consume
large amounts like potassium magnesium
but iron and calcium for example
are much more difficult to eliminate so
those are two minerals that you don't
want to take large amounts on a regular
basis
so if you have arthritis and
you want to potentially see if it's an
iron overload situation there's several
things you can do you know stop the iron
supplements start improving your liver
take a remedy like phytic acid or green
tea or curcitin or even donate blood and
see if your arthritis gets better now
for more information on how to improve
liver function
this is the next video you should watch
right here
you